anh alo
anh alo alo
hỗ trợ Ninh tí Gala về tai nghe của mình
có vấn đề à
em chả bao giờ OK Chào ông
thì buổi hôm nay Nhưng mình có bảo là
hôm nay sẽ được tiền sẽ chấm nốt cho các
nhóm và là
ở một vài nhóm thì cần chữa trực tiếp
cốt thì mình sẽ kiểu gọi Google Maps để
mà để mà để những nhóm nào
biết nhỏ lâu
anh alo
sự tích nhỏ
cho biết cô bé đâu nhỉ
hỗ trợ xăng
nãy thì tôi mới đang chỉnh mà thì thôi
Anh nói là kiểu hôm nay sẽ những nhóm
nào
ừ ừ
em
muốn chữa đoán
Ừ tùy bình luận
Ê bà chuẩn bị gọi Google Maps ngoại
không cần là chú trình cả cái đồ án đâu
chị chương trình qua là muốn làm tình
năm nào thì xong rồi mình sẽ ngồi cốt
cùng bọn đấy
review cốt cầu xổ thứ à
thủ chữa cho một vài nhóm ăn nó ngoại
hôm trước ban chấm rồi nhưng mà nhóm thứ
ông chủ nhật
Ừ đợi tí
I love you
ờ ờ
chắc chồng nhóm 23 bảo là nó chỉ qua một
vài cái kê mới sang ngắm 24 nhé năm nay
tư thì
với vụ này rồi như thế sang nhóm 25 đi
em muốn chữa ta bây giờ ừ ok ok đi
ở ngoài không dùng vi format trong hơi
bị xấu thật doctor
khi cây net này
I Won't wash PT
He has Epoxy Taurus nhập ờ ờ
a good night
cho iPad App Store lưu lại
nó dễ hiểu
Ừ thôi file
tủ bếp
a where
que ngày số người
và luôn được để lấy mỗi một này mà nó
nhọn
từ ngày được
Ừ nếu mà tồn tại thì ăn ăn Linh khác tôi
nhớ không lầm là mình có thể gọi đến an
ninh thẳng luôn không cần à
thế nhưng nhưng mà thực tế là không nên
dùng an ninh không không không nên dùng
an ninh của P và dùng hàm mà dùng hàng
Beer and của chính Neville thì nó hợp lý
hơn cũng không không dùng được an ninh
chỗ này nhưng ý tôi là gọi hàng bila đấy
thì
Ừ thì ông cứ gọi thôi không cần phải
kiểm tra Nó tồn tại hay không
Ừ nó vẫn xóa và nó sẽ không báo lỗi khi
mà phải không còn tại không phải lo
Ừ cái pha này mình có thể dùng à
cách dùng hàm store để lưu lại thì nó sẽ
tự động cho nó viết ra tên cũng theo
kiểu nghe không không cần mất công ngay
interphase này của bạn này
thôi
xe Xipo
Ừ ok import này Ừ rồi tôi xem cái file
import của bạn ơi nhé
bộ bài tây bạ không dùng hết đồ dùng cái
vít hết đi nè thành ra là phải nhập kiểu
như này thôi có không lên kiểu nhà không
nên đôi khi sẽ không hiểu và thay đổi
thay đổi số cột là sẽ hiển nó bị lỗi Tôi
nghĩ là không nên làm như kiểu như này
à à
khi export này
em bán cái này lại cố hết pin à
Em mở cái này là bit Trinh ơi
Ừ cái điểm gì nhé
anh sex sinh string
Ừ tôi
Ừ ok flash bios Asus
ê ê đê ê
bây giờ chưa có gì mấy cho bạn này cũng
chưa làm tính năng gì đó cậu Dạ quan
trọng lắm nhỉ
em chưa chưa Cho làm thế năng chính của
cái trang web mà sku
a tiếp theo nhằm tiếp theo là ờ ờ
bộ phận kêu
cái này hình như là
có giống nhau hôm trước
anh em nhé
ở camden
ăn Tết
đề kiểm tra
I can dien tu dien
em lấy ra để điền vào
Anh từng nói đi ừ Plus cái giống cái cốt
mà tôi đã đi mua này
Ừ nhưng mà thử cái hôm đấy tôi bảo đây
một là làm cái cách này hay là mình có
thể hít with ngay ở cái đoạn mà
em biết ở ngày đoạn này được rồi mình sẽ
ít à
Á Châu đình Nếu có thì mình sẽ trở về
ta0 đề này mình sẽ up cái tên này đúng
cái kiểu như này để mình lấy ra cái điểm
danh của sinh viên xong rồi mình sẽ
chung lấy ra kiểu này nó dễ để một cách
ở nhà thôi làm cho mạc ở lại được
anh không sai không sai
anh bởi về cơ bản thì nó vẫn phải mất
công truy vấn tương đương thế thôi nó
không khác gì cả
này con này cho cũng hơi chạy được không
cần sửa nữa
bạn này làm điện ra nhà nhớ bạn làm điểm
danh thì hôm trước mặt tôi chưa xong rồi
đấy gần như xong rồi thì bây giờ các bạn
xong cái tính năng xong những cái tính
năng chính kiểu như thế thì các bạn cần
đến mấy chị ở đầu vào nhập và thôi các
bạn Công lịch sử lý là đầu ra
lịch sử nghĩa là sao nghĩa ha khi mà
hiển thị ra thì không phải thì chị đã
đúng với thứ mình vừa nhập mà về sau còn
làm thống kê hay là tính toán cái gì đó
giống như tôi từng bảo là cốt là có thể
hiển thị ra là là lớp đã được điểm danh
ai chưa này có bao nhiêu sinh viên hay
nghỉ sinh viên là nghĩ nhiều cấm thi các
sứ giả sử đấy được thi nhé nên nói cho
mà cứ hiển thị số lượt điểm danh của
từng bạn chẳng hạn đấy là một cách mà
nói chung là rất nhiều kiểu
về việc làm cái đấy như nào thì
sao để hôm nào tôi sẽ thử chỉ mới ông
sau
EX3 teeth and
ở bảng giá thiết truyền cổ vào được
Online crack
bằng
hỗ trợ import bằng xịn bằng Excel thì nó
sẽ nặn phết
vào hôm 12
từ 12 lần
ở gà
khi quan hệ để luôn ngay tại đây
thì các bạn nên để nó sẽ là con tuần này
nói vết này à
Ừ rồi à hay thua càng ai đúng
Âm Nhạc
thế này sau đó thì các bạn để luôn cái
thai hộ ở đây như này để dễ chỉnh sửa
được không cần phải tạm cái năm đâu
không cần tại 500 triệu này
con gà PC Nga Trắng nước nhé được quay
vết Tại sao quay vết thì nó sẽ hiểu được
ạ chỉ tồn tại trong controller này nó sẽ
chung à nhưng khai báo về cái kiểu của
là cái đấy nó có nó sẽ được kế thừa hay
nó sẽ được dùng ở chỗ khác hay không Nếu
giả sử chỉ dùng trong mỗi mày kể Tăng
trình này thì có thể dùng Private hãy
Huế
em chưa chưa có gì cả
mà à tiền nhóm Lớp Trưởng chuẩn bị để mà
làm ngoại
à à đã sửa ra cho rồi
a mắt
a section lấy ra này này
truyền status
từ micro apartment I Miss You
Ừ ok
nhà đất Đợi tí đợi tí
ưu điểm danh này có Tik Tok rồi nè
Ừ Ừ
munn attendant là như thế nào
Cho tôi cho tôi cứ tưởng để làm cái điểm
danh cho sinh viên đều là ra kiểu chấm
công Ok nó chấm công kê Jackie này que
các bạn làm vào này nhanh chỉ cần dùng
nhao nhao được
nó sẽ tự Converse cho mấy ông kia thế
có ship mày City cũng không có vai biết
à Bây giờ mình chuyển cái tôi điểm danh
ở cho quá khứ được đúng không
ở trong nghĩa trong ngày hôm nay được
cái điểm danh nửa đêm điểm dành cho ca
một ca buổi sáng được thế không được
không ạ
em à đương nhiên có chuyện bếp lửa này
đúng không Ok Ok
à à
cho chị xem flash
Ừ ok check in các thứ thứ ok ok
Ừ nhưng mà vẫn điểm này anh phải cho cá
khác hơi sai đúng không mình nên làm ba
đến nó là đấy
chữ cái nha Không biết hoa mỗi chữ cái
đầu đâu
chất vẫn phải vài đất ở bên này cả phần
mềm cả bác lên chứ
không biết nhóm biết cái khác như nào
khi phun lên mày Channel nêm Express
hiển thị nè bạn phải làm như thế này
đúng không là không không cần điều này
lắm Nếu mà em muốn thêm mấy cái này vào
trong từng cái này thì em dùng cái hạ
pen để truyền thêm vào được sẽ append
được này ngay
sẽ truyền những cái mà em muốn và thôi
xử như thế này
mã
số trên đồ lên ngay nhé Được không cần
thấy có tài này đâu nha Không cần đâu
hiểu chứ
anh về đây em sẽ có
Anh ta sẽ như này và phải thế xong
cho
mik bé cho thỉnh thoảng là tôi không
quay mặt vào phía Mickey với tôi đăng
với mặt màn hình này nhìn mà Mấy ông thi
thoảng dùng cái format của ai hỗ trợ nhé
u
vợ chồng Cốt và lời khuyên là luôn enter
trước mọi the return nhanh nhìn cho tiện
này xử lý toàn bộ một bên này sò Return
B này tôi thường hay kiểu những cách A
như này nữa đó lấy trọn bộ input
em ở cách làm một cái xử lý mà càng ngày
enter xuống dòng như thế này thì nó tiền
đấy lại đúng kiểu dặm kiểu như này
ngay đó Trần Anh sẽ có các thứ thôi Nó
tiền cái này cũng sẽ thế anh sẽ cậu Để
như này luôn để dấu phẩy em cô ấy với
sao thích mình nhắc đến nhưng cái nữa
Cốt nó sẽ trông cửa lại sẽ thoáng hơn
rất rất nhiều thì chưa ạ
Vì sao update lại có Wendy còn ghét này
em có một thằng đó mà Thế thằng này phải
file mày chứ
à à
anh em đúng chứ
à Mà thực ra em đã ghi kiểu như này rồi
thì đóng lẽ em phải đi theo kiểu là
có ai à
Minh rồi nữa không cần gì phải khai báo
thêm họ sẽ là ờ ờ
vì sao mình gọi đến nêm này
em gái thế này
à à
Em hãy soi vitamin xếp này
Ừ cái như này chỉ ngắn gọn đây thôi
khi con Đây đây đây Nói chung là chị đại
khái ngắn gọn ngay thôi nghe chưa
anh với em truyền lên cái biển đi tao
mình mà
ở Nghệ An nó biến thành đối tượng nó sẽ
quay hộ cho em Dạo này rồi
chị sẽ chỉ đơn giản sửa lại cái tên mới
cho nó xong lưu lại anh sao em thấy
Return lại chính nó đã làm cái kiểu bưu
của ai kia thì nó sẽ trả về không trả về
không trả về view mà trả về kiểu api để
mà trả lời Nói chung là chả với dữ liệu
Thôi xong rồi bên bên fan những dùng
Facebook ra Swift về đi lên ok
đại khá những nhóm rồi chùm qua trong
một vài nhóm nhóm nào muốn chấm chi tiết
hơn Thì đấy bây giờ Nhóm nào cần tôi
chấm chi tiết hơn thì có thể nhắn tin
nữa ngọn anh ở đây không phải nhắn tin
mà cứ vào thằng ôm ít mình sẽ gọi Mít
nhé
ở nhà tôi sẽ chọn mít thôi tôi sẽ chấm
cho các bạn
sẽ
và Mít để gọi nha à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
những ngày này rồi Ok ok à
Ừ anh chấm qua nhóm của sumo rồi em ạ Có
gì thì em sẽ lại đi ừ
số miền Bắc
ở nhóm Em đẩy Viettel lên rồi đúng không
nhỉ nhỉ
ở Việt Nam
tin tức cập nhật
mới thấy cập nhật ở đây em chết tơ đây
rồi em
cả em ạ chứ chưa có file mới
ừ ừ
anh không em siêu chảy đôi màn hình nữa
đ.d pattinson dùng được irwin không Anh
có bản chất là cho Jackson kệ lô quần
đấy bản chất thì nó vẫn là chạy câu truy
vấn như bình thường thôi nhưng mà chẳng
qua nó sẽ nó sẽ khởi tạo đối tượng khi
mà xử lý một vài vấn đề gì đó lại sẽ
khởi tạo đối tượng với bản chất thì nó
vẫn chạy qua câu truy vấn ashworth nhưng
thưởng nên là dp trong sân Thì nó nó làm
ở cái phiên phiên để mà kiểu mình mình
xử lý câu app allows Và nếu có vấn đề gì
bắn bắn lỗi về thì nó sẽ rô bác nó sẽ
khôi phục lại đi thoải mái
Khi
à à
Ừ ok ok
đấy có
à À nghĩa là bây giờ là đầu tiên là
classes.jar classes thì nó không phải là
thực thể có cái này chỉ ra tao bây cho
mày thể nó nhỉ Nếu mà đã Ta mây thì em
nổi ở kia rồi à sai đấy nói được cả là
nhiều nhiều như này một cái cái cái cái
nối này anh chỉ đơn ăn uống bình thường
thôi chứ em không có nối gạo nhiều nhiều
hai được vậy Nó là một mà
đi ăn trưa
thì ở đây có
là một sinh viên có thể thuộc nhiều lớp
học phải đúng không xong rồi lớp học thì
có theo môn này theo ca này làm theo dễ
đúng không xong rồi theo thứ tự đúng
không Thì cái lịch học nó sẽ là wish ID
à mình đây đời ID không thì ra không cần
cuốc đi nữa bỏ bê đi đi này nó sẽ gọi
đết luôn từ cái đếch thì sẽ lấy được Quý
Tây cụ thể là là thứ mấy rồi bỏ cái này
đi Này mình mình sẽ classid ok rồi này K
có bỏ đi vào vì trong lớp có ca rồi mà
nên bỏ cái này đi làm em muốn để sửa để
mà kêu mà nhắn tin có gì chị thì mình sẽ
co lại để mà tâm nữa
à À nghĩa là về sau có thể là kiểu bị
lùi lịch đúng không Nghĩa là một hôm nhà
cố định để Ừ ừ
Nhưng mà thỉnh thoảng sẽ con luôn nô lệ
đúng không Nhưng mà chính vì như thế nó
lại Hiền lo bài toán mà khó lên mày tao
đơn giản trước đãi đó là chỉ hiển thị ra
để mình làm cái tự động để mà sắp xếp
lịch mà còn nếu bây giờ là em muốn đổi
cái thì thì sẽ ảnh hưởng đến lớp khác do
sự thế Ở đây em chưa có làm lớp học em
chưa biết được kiểu đấy bởi vì a giả sử
em có 20 lớp thôi chồng ạ 20 phòng học
thì ra thấy nó lại lớp 20 phòng học của
trường ạ Mà lớp của em có nhiều đúng
không Thì được thì em phải sắp xếp sao
cho
cho nó kín phòng đúng không Chưa kể là
còn có cái phòng Hồi trước ở Trường
Giang ngồi đấy nó không còn có kiểu là
có phòng nó chứa được nhiều sinh viên có
phòng thì nó chỉ chứa được nợ ít sinh
viên thôi Ở Ngạn đấy nghĩa là có phòng
thì có thể ghé 2 lớp được có phòng thì
không ghép được và Vân ngay hội để làm
được ca là rất quan trọng đương nhiên về
sau anh cũng cho cái được sửa ca nhưng
mà bạn để mà Và thậm chí phải có thậm
chí có giáo viên nghỉ thì có thể là cho
lớp khác học vào hôm đấy cũng được nhái
kiểu học nói chung Vân Như cái đấy nó
lại hoàn toàn nó khó hơn khó hơn nhiều
nghe nghĩa là làm mình cứ làm bài toán
kiểu cơ bản xong rồi thống kê các thứ
mọi thứ cơ bản chưa đã còn về sau muốn
nâng cao mới phát triển thì được nhà về
sau thêm cũng được mà hiểu để sau mình
vẫn thể thêm thêm sau còn hiện tại thì
bây giờ mình
Ừ mình không hẳn là dùng từ tối giản đâu
mà mình cứ phải dứt điểm cái bài toán là
kiểu Ừ Bây giờ cứ giả sử gọi nữ cố định
hết đi á
em làm được cái bài toán đấy xong đi á
sau đó đi về sao em muốn làm theo kiểu
là tùy chỉnh theo ý người dùng người
dùng muốn làm thêm những cái gì thì có
thể ta mừng sau được chứ nhưng còn bài
toán Lúc đầu là cứ để cho mặc định hết
cố định thì em giải quyết nó như thế nào
hiểu chứ
cái tầm xóa cái ca đêm
ừ ừ
Ừ thế thì mình sẽ có thù với lại ok ok
này sau đó đi có điểm danh sinh viên này
tiềm nay lịch này không xa tốt tình
trạng này để xem để xem thiếu gì nhỉ
giáo viên thì không có giáo viên à Mày
có giáo viên nữ thì ngon những hình
thằng Mirror
à À nghĩa là giáo viên nối xanh cổ một
giáo viên dạy nhớ mà cái phải toán một
lớp thì chỉ có một giáo viên thôi nhưng
mà không cần phải
có một lớp thì kiểu gì vẫn có một giáo
viên thì nỗi Thảo từ user xanh class
không không không cần được cơ bản hai
đứa em ạ Em đặt tên không Bởi vì em ở
đây em và tên nó sẽ nó sẽ bị khó trong
người làm nhìn qua chưa hiểu thì em vẫn
có thể đổi tên này nó không sao cả em sẽ
class cái cái chưa tiêu Lần này em là
tên ơi toj đi đấy tiếp theo ở cái bảng
flash này em ở một thêm một cột nữa đó
Cột kiểu tí chơi đi Hoàn toàn lịch trời
Đi xa cũng dễ hiểu rồi hoa đấy
Ừ vậy thì thế xong rồi mình sẽ nối hẳn
về Loser ở được rồi chứ này
ở đây là số buổi học đúng không
Ừ
ok
ok đấy nhé em về cơ bản thì chỉ cần sửa
qua như thế có nhà mình mình Thứ ba chỉ
cần ít bảng Thế thôi nha mình giải quyết
được bài toán đã đúng không ạ
Ừ ok đây ạ
được là là tôi khi là tối chấm thì
mày Ông sai là mấy ông thiệt đúng không
tranh thủ chữa các thứ thứ
ừ ừ
Xin chào em
à à
Ừ Anh nghe rõ rồi Ok ok rồi em
ừ ừ
ạ
Bây giờ anh
ờ em em ừ em chia sẻ màn hình rồi chị
bậy cũng được tiện
ở nhà mà em cần chấm Cái gì đã bình tĩnh
em cần trầm cái gì đã
em chầm chậm qua cốc à hay như thế nào
Ừ anh đang ở
Bây giờ ngồi sửa lại nếu là tôi tôi nản
lắm đấy tôi Chứ thật những mà tôi Giả sử
đang làm nửa chừng người tự nhiên thời
đập ra bây làm lại thì nạn đấy
Khi mà mình mình đang làm thì bản thân à
Mình giúp cai nghiện là chủ yếu làm cái
rút kinh nghiệm mà nhiều mà
ạ Bây giờ là mấy lúc để đang Ừ đúng
nghĩa là tham gia khóa học của tôi thì
mấy ông mất thời gian có
a a không phải dùng từ mất là bỏ thời
gian nó bỏ công sức thôi ngon
anh Bởi vì em đã em đang nghe cả Google
mít và
được hoặc là tắt tiếng của YouTube bây
giờ được à
hihi thì bây giờ anh đang bảo là em buồn
anh thì view đã ra bây giờ ổn rồi đúng
không
không biết lên review cốt tính năng Nếu
thế thì bây giờ em đọc Anh Anna đi để
anh thử
Em thử ngoài việc review có thì anh sẽ
sửa cốc luôn cho em nếu có đi
cậu
ở
chỗ nó sẽ miễn phí hơn hàng teamview à
anh gửi sang biết nhá Ừ
à à
Ừ ok à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ ok chưa nhỉ à
diện với em thử trình bày sao mà em đang
bây giờ em muốn muốn anh xem có tính
năng gì thì anh sẽ thử đi
địt lỗi giao diện
ở
à à
ở bên này của em à
anh
[âm nhạc]
Ừ anh đang chưa hình dung để làm gì lắm
Thôi kệ đi
ok
Bây giờ tính tình em muốn để mô tính
năng gì cơ
a
di đà phật ý
tình nào không tính năng tính năng chấm
công của em trông như thế nào thì anh
gửi cho em ạ ạ
sản xuất tăng số thẻ
công
nhân chưa phát trận thuốc nói với tài
khoản
Cho xem hình ảnh
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
cái này đi Em có
đó là thằng thằng trưởng trưởng phòng nó
sẽ là tạo tài khoản và nó sẽ mật khẩu nó
sẽ tự động chỉ là ngẫu nhiên
qua qua và gửi qua mail thì không sau đó
thì sau đó thì vừa khi mà người dùng bấm
là cái link đấy thì sẽ sang cái trang
đăng nhập như này nhưng mà Thì đúng như
em ạ là khi mà người dùng nhập mật khẩu
mới này sẽ là mật khẩu mới luôn của
người ta hiểu không nghĩa là
ý nghĩa là bản chất người ta phải nhập
mật khẩu cũ ở trong cái Linh đây 10 đã
bấm vào đã thấy chẳng thế
anh không được khi nào mới có điện thoại
là bạn
một Ờ thế hai hay nhiều nơi và nó không
làm bảo mật thật kỹ để nó rẽ là không
cần phải sinh tại mật khẩu ngẫu nhiên nó
chỉ cần sinh ra một cái link ngẫu nhiên
thôi Khi mà bấm vào cái link đấy À gần
như là là chắc chắn là cái link đấy ấm
theo email này rồi thì không cần phải tự
động Điền email nữa chỉ cần nhập mật
khẩu mới thôi cho
làm theo kiểu như này của em thì thực ra
là người dùng lúc đầu người ta không
hiểu ra không hiểu chứ
vì vậy người ta lúc đầu mày nó sẽ có mật
khẩu đâu Đúng không Nó sẽ đi hỏi gì chứ
Nghe
những bài hát chi tiết nhỏ thôi cái
không không không quan trọng trong Thế
tính năng đồ án này nên bỏ qua được
Ừ ok
Biển Xanh
ta có
mới
ừ ừ
anh mới về rồi mà
Bình ơi
Ừ ok Nói chung là điểm danh thế rồi còn
còn gì nữa nhỉ
em
tính ăn gì nữa
Khả năng hôm nay à
viên này điểm danh này đúng không ạ
khi con bên anh còn thiếu
điểm danh anh
hai đến ba sau khi thằng
quản lý
nó sẽ à
ở bên quản lý về thử xem nhân viên đã
điểm danh như thế nào thì kiểu gì ý
em quản lý nhân viên à
[âm nhạc]
à à Ê mày có thêm sửa xóa thì làm nhanh
mà
Ừ quan trọng cái tính năng quan trọng là
cái tính năng quản lý giống như bảo đấy
quản lý để mà xem mà xem nhân viên đã
kịp ra như thế nào rồi
nhà quản lý Để xem à
ừ ừ
không
biết cái này là lỗi bên view
Ở nhà thấy nó báo lỗi bên tiêu kìa à
ê ê
xe
Honda đây anh xem cho
thế này lỗi tại Giọng tại cái này
xin
lỗi dòng nào xem sex chơi cách chơi của
nó này
như vậy Tỉ Lệ Dĩnh
vì nó không có Nó không có cái á vì nó
không có điểm danh thì không thể bắt
được rồi được
em em phải kiểm tra nó có điểm danh đã
các
bạn bạn kia đang bảo là kéo cốt từ bên
main về kìa à
Khi bình minh hạnh phúc
nói chung à các bạn vẫn còn đang
Anh đang vừa làm sao mà vừa đẩy lên theo
ca lúc mà để môi Vậy lúc nào để môi
không được Kiểu như anh lỗi là là đi
xuống đấy em
ừ ừ
ai cho hôm hôm bảo vệ có bảo vệ đồ án là
mấy ông sẽ phải rất là nói chung là cố
cố để nói chuyên nghiệp nhất có thể mấy
ông coi hình vuông mà mày ông ý nhất là
đi xem một buổi sát Anh ấy thì
mình cũng sẽ hiểu là kiểu mọi thứ nó lên
cầm chuẩn như thế nào không ạ
chứ không phải lỗi này lỗi vẫn đông như
anh vừa bảo rồi
Em chưa có chưa có điện một bạn chưa có
điểm danh anh này ra nó vào lỗi rồi đấy
U22 định ra kẹo lịch là hai nhà mặc định
chọn mặc định chọn mấy cái thời gian kia
edsa đây đúng không Ok
thai hay chưa Ok
à à
Thì
[âm nhạc]
sớm muộn
các quốc gia không
làm gì
ca nhạc
cái
w29 nghĩa là gì tuần là cái gì đấy à
chỗ này làm gì Cái này à
Nhưng mà về chưa Làm xong nữa không Để
hôm nào sao làm xong thì anh thử chữa
cho nhé xem như nào nhé
anh
nhìn Giao Thiện chồng cũng mẹ sự sai đấy
à à
ê ê
Ừ ok
ở đây tuần w để tuần
tuần 29 Ok nhưng mà chưa có chưa có cái
chưa có cái gì
bạn Thành Long mà bảo là để hôm sau để
mô Ok chả có cái này tuần này hôm sau để
modi Thế còn phần nào em làm đến phần
nào nhé phần
Ok thường nói qua phần Seo Sem
à à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ở
Quản lý à
[âm nhạc]
anh đọc truyện Miền Tây
I
[âm nhạc]
thì không có một cái file đầy đủ các
thông tin của nhân viên rồi à
cả file CSV để khi cần những cái gì
chỉ
cần phải điền những đi bí ẩn có những
cái ở cần có những cột như thế nào
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Khi dịch
anh đúng không Thực ra là anh để mua cho
các bạn được một chuyện các bạn phải
tính nói vụ đấy Đó là là một là cho
export trong cho họ mọi người xem một
cái file mẫu để người ta điền vào trong
cái váy đấy đúng không hay là hay là
phải hiển thị ra giống như hồi trước anh
làm cho bên trường phải thị rõ ra là cần
phải có những cây cột này khuôn này phút
này cô này có thể không quan trọng người
bỏ qua gì đó để người dùng biết được là
bé sẽ gửi cho em một cái file save Ê nó
phải chuẩn chuẩn Cái định dạng như nào
Đúng không còn nếu mà bây giờ là nhập
cái Facebook lên thì ok để file chuẩn ở
trên má em nhưng mà người dùng người
khác người ta được biết đâu đúng không
người ta sẽ không biết nó không biết nếu
mà người dùng mà ngốc nghếch người dùng
không dùng não đúng không Thế là cứ nhập
vừa một cái fiving ở đó vào thì chị sẽ
lỗi gì chứ
ạ Vâng cái thì mình mình phải có một cái
mẫu sẵn hộ phải CV để người dùng hiểu là
phải xếp về đấy cân rồi có những cái cột
Như nào Như nào chẳng hạn đấy đúng không
nhập vào
giản rồi còn cái còn còn cái nào đâu
em làm ổn nó kiểu tưởng mình đỡ phải thị
nhiều
các phòng ban đi
ạ bây giờ bấm trackpad của em là sẽ cái
gì đầu tiên à
I
Met with này thì
A Time
sau thời gian này
không không trách nhưng buổi sáng
em
à ok
anh
thêm thời gian thì nó có ba
đặt cài đặt Ban đầu cái này không không
dùng nhiều đúng không thì đầy nó ở cuối
đúng không ạ
ờ ờ
Hiển thị giống bên quản lý
Ok cái này thì còn cái này cần ưu tiên
lên trên này cái file kia là cái gì
Ừ
cái này này cũng giống Đây là phải đọc
sao thì bên này qua cài đặt thời gian
đi muộn à
ok nghĩa là xong rồi tính đang thêm rồi
xóa cơ bản rồi nhưng mà còn ở bên Kế
toán cũng như là bên chiều phòng thì nó
cả điểm danh nữa điểm danh Xem xem cái
điểm danh nữa thì ra để hôm sau xem để
mô nào nghỉ để tuần sau nhé Tuần sau cả
hai cùng ngon rồi mà cùng để mua qua và
Thành Long thì đang bảo là em chưa thống
nhất với
bạn đấy về cách trình bày này thì cả hai
cũng phải thống nhất lại về cách trình
bày để cho nó hợp nó cùng một khuôn đã
chứ mỗi người một ý với thằng Gà hơi say
mới có hai người thôi mỗi ngủ đi Không
biết vì sao lạc việc theo nhóm thì nó sẽ
loạn ngào nữa đúng không Ok
Anh cảm ơn em
Dạ vâng
ừ ừ
rồi để mình góp ý Mình chữa luôn cho ông
gió tâm sự tuổi hồng được gì
kê cho em
ạ ok ok
à Dạ giờ em chia sẻ màn hình anh nhỉ Em
em muốn trình bày cái gì nhỉ
em cần à quên em muốn trình bày về tính
năng điểm danh Em làm này điểm danh sinh
viên
Cứ thử để mua qua xem à
anh nhé
Ừ
ok ok
ừ ừ
à à
hả em tắt tiếng cái này thế
nghe tiếng Anh đi lấy thế này à
có anh ở đây rồi tắt đi à
anh
em em 9 bài
Vì ai em làm về tính năng điểm danh thì
đầu tiên thì sẽ có chọn qua chọn chuyên
ngành chọn lớp và chọn môn học để cần
điểm danh
sau khi bấm chọn thì sẽ hiển thị ra toàn
bộ danh sách thuộc những cái lớp đang
học đó
à À đây là điểm danh ở bên bên giả Vũ
Đúng anh ạ để giáo viên gì cả nên giáo
viên thì em chưa làm
ở biển đảo viên mới quan trọng hơn đúng
không ở bên giáo viên thì cần đi là em
em làm cái tính năng của phân công đâu
nhỉ
phân công cụ
sự phân công ra giáo vụ như thế nào giáo
viên phải như thế nào không phân công
giáo viên dạy lớp nào ấy
tăng chưa là cân Công Hạ thì bàn chân
Nếu em là phân công rồi thì sẽ hiển thị
lớp môn và viên đã dậy thôi à đã làm dậy
thôi thì có phải chọn khóa chọn này nó
không rõ là và viên một giáo viên chỉ
dạy được một vài lớp thôi nó dậy sẽ kiểu
hiển thị ra ít hơn ok lại khó ở đây là
một ca sáng rồi nhập tình trạng đi học
Ok
thì em để mặc định thì chọn toàn là đi
học
muốn chọn răng chứ những này
thì khi bấm biển rang thì
A
lô bảo đi ăn dùng dịch ly để không tải
lại trang ah
Ừ Ok Mà bây giờ tải lại trang thì À thì
sẽ
Tại sao thì ra
đi vẫn giữ nguyên như thế này Nhưng mà
ví dụ như em điểm xa trang điểm danh cho
ca chiều đấy ạ thì chi vẫn tải lại trang
thì em đang không lấy lại được ca chiều
ấy
Ví dụ như thế
không mời vì bản chất là có cái như này
đó là các bạn đang bị một cái là các bạn
cũng hơi bị giảm sút cái nghề ra Suite
là kiểu không lót vải trang nhưng nó sẽ
có nhược điểm là nó không để hàng địa
chỉ
ung thư da là thời gian mình có thể đẩy
lên hai địa chỉ chữ cái như này kể về
sau mình có thể tải lại chạm dễ hỏi mình
quay lại ra nó cũng dễ mình sẽ là kiểu
đẩy lên cả khóa trước nhàng lớp môn với
ca cùng để lên hai nguyện chỉ trả ạ Đấy
thì thì thì nó sẽ rẽ em em hiểu đi Anh
không vào vợ được thì thì nó sẽ cậu khi
mình tải lại trang hoặc khi mình để
tránh cũ thì nó sẽ tự động lấy lại cái
thông tin cũ theo đúng cái mới cá Minh
Chiến 2 địa chỉ ra được cái đấy cách sửa
khi con cá rồi à Ừ ok ờ ra điểm danh
tính năng quan trọng nữa là phải đẩy lên
chứ cùng những đại về sau sẽ có thêm
những thống kê thì đẩy lên sau nhưng gần
như trang của em thì tính năng chính để
cái điện cho anh còn mấy cái mấy cái
kiểu khóa hai chân nhàng thì mình nhập
vào đầu năm thôi còn về sau mình cũng
gần như không vừa động vào thì mình sẽ
đầy xuống cuối được
những những những cái nào mà hay dùng là
sự điểm danh này sinh viên này Đấy chẳng
hạn thế để lên trên này đấy Ờ cái buổi
học kia là gì nhỉ
A và phân công cụ ngôn này có bao nhiêu
buổi đấy à
Ừ để em làm điểm danh ví dụ như là
Ừ cái đấy phải nằm trong môn thế nhỉ nằm
trong Moon đã nó làm cho môi mà
ở môn này có nhiều Buổi thì dở nằm trong
muôn màu đúng không ạ
cột có số buổi thôi
các bạn
à còn gì cũng để đẻ nhớ đây ạ thì cá em
ôm cái này sang bên giáo viên để làm
tiền tai nghe máy phải làm một phân công
đã em Em chưa làm phân công hay là không
vào đa bay phân công I Got A Boy phân
công em quá rồi ạ Chị làm gì đấy Ok thì
phải làm việc phân công đội trong thời
trang web của em để phân biệt danh này
thì sẽ có bay khó một cái A phân công
này tiếp theo là cái điểm danh này tiếp
theo nữa là khi bị điểm danh xong mình
về sau sẽ làm thống kê để mẹ hiển thị ra
là kiểu cần là nói cho hiển thị thông
tin mà mình đã điểm danh ở nó như là
thôi thế thôi ạ
thế này thì mình cần bổ sung nốt Thế mày
cái đấy rồi có gì để anh chậm sau Ok
anh ạ ạ
cho con con nhóm nào nữa
chậm quá các bạn hiểu không Có vài nhóm
tám hơi và nhóm lại có làm nhưng mà
không ngại trình bày bị chậm nữa
Ê mày không đâu hết rồi
nha
chồng qua một vài nhóm ờ
e k thì à cá nhân Các bạn thấy đấy thì
sao gà Các bạn cũng đang hình dung đăng
hình dung được là mình phải làm những
cái rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà ờ
Ừ nhưng mà các bạn vẫn chưa biết cốt
chuyên nghiệp chủ yếu là thế Và chưa
biết là mình cần phải làm thêm những cái
gì chứ về cơ bản thì các bạn cũng hình
dung cũng hình dung được là cậu à trang
web của các bạn đang như nào rồi tôi
thấy thực ra để một cái bước tiến rất là
ổn bởi vì à bản thân tôi hồi trước chính
chính mình ngồi trước ở cậu làm mình còn
anh chẳng hiểu là mình đang làm cái gì
nhiều không Còn các bạn bây giờ chắc à
Tôi vẫn tự tin và
không không không không nói vừa Các bạn
có thông minh hơn tôi sau Hồi đấy Không
em tự tin chắc là tôi đang kèm cặp các
bạn gọi là
chu đáo hơn so với các thầy Hồi trước
kiểu chăm tôi qua đấy à Tôi đúng kiểu ạ
ông thầy cứ sao để tải đấy rồi tự tự bơi
thôi không không có kiểu kèm cặp kỹ kiểu
nhà đâu cũng không có kêu đấy Con bây
giờ thấy các bạn có vẻ là tàng hình dung
được là mình cần phải làm những điều gì
Cái thứ lại thế là về cơ bản thì tôi
nghĩa là ổn
bây giờ tâm sự à Thực ra bây giờ mấy ông
muốn tâm sự cũng được là tôi gần đây
khái có khá nhiều cái thứ mà
đi đám ma Kiều oa
áo kiểu Dạ suy nghĩ nhiều
mà em không cần trợ nữa Tại tôi phạt tắt
mít nhé
mình chưa Mình chưa gợi ý Kiểu các bạn
là xa nó sẵn Học Cách Để bữa hôm sau nhé
Để tôi vui tôi vui nốt lại đây Cái buổi
hôm sau tôi dễ Chị ơi mẹ ông
lạnh này
ưu điểm đại học Trường đại học Hồi trước
tôi thể thao nam điểm mà Nam ma
35 tôi tự nhiên năm tôi Thi dạy học thì
lại là năm nó bắt đầu kiểu gặp cái quy
chế là cầu ở
thi cả tốt nghiệp và thi đại học thành
gia là
Hai ra là năm đấy nó hơi bị sai sai theo
kiểu như thế này nó là được 8 điểm chỉ
rất là dễ còn trên 8 Địa 9 10 hiện rất
là khó Hồi đấy thì tôi tôi thì ra là tôi
một thanh niên Hồi trước thôi khá giỏi
toán khá giỏi nhưng mà tôi không thích
toàn mấy nữa Tôi thích chuyên về lí và
với khá sẽ nói chung Tôi đam mê Lý nhất
sau đó thì tôi muốn học cả tiếng Anh cậu
muốn không hoàn chuyên Tiếng Anh nói cho
tôi thích học tiếng Anh Anh trở lên thì
ý nghĩa và khối A1 không ạ thì của đấy
thôi không muốn chuyên toán nữa này là
tôi học Toán quốc là chỉ mong cậu được
tán thôi mà tôi nghĩ là 8 là một cái mức
Điệp khá rồi đấy nhưng mà năm của tôi
năm thí điểm và kiểu gồm cả
tất
cả thi đại học với cả thi tốt nghiệp
thành ra là 57 điểm Toán gần như là hai
công đức tám lần nhưng nếu thời đi khiến
cho là cái điểm 8 toán tôi trái nghĩa gì
mấy nữa đấy
còn 9 10 luôn như tôi không ôn chuyên
nên là cũng không nên là 90 rồi và nhưng
mà năm đầy nó bị buồn cười đẹp lại đề gì
nó dễ hơn cả như thế nhưng mà điểm cộng
thì điểm cộng kiểu dạng bất kỳ ai không
phải ở Hà Nội đều được cộng điểm đấy thì
nó điểm cộng với nó vẫn thế thành ra là
những cái bạn ở Hà Nội như tôi ở nhà nó
có một tí một tí thiệt thòi cho cậu lại
nếu mà ông muốn hơn niềm mấy người kia
không phải giỏi vãi Dương bởi vì những
cái được chín mười ra giỏi được 8 thì
lại rất là dễ ra là cho
ở nhà thứ nhất ở những cái người ngoại
tình đấy được chín được 8 nhiều lắm điểm
lúc nào sẵn sàng bằng nhau nhưng mà cộng
thêm một đống điểm cộng nữa thấy ai cũng
hơn ai là ai ai được gần nhau lắm đấy
Chi xem được cái cổng nhiều điểm cộng
hơn chứ không phải là thi xem ai ai được
nhiều điểm hơn rồi buồn cười nói như thế
bởi tôi nhớ chính xác nào tôi tôi lúc
đầu nó sẽ thử một trăm năm về lớp đấy
trong cái danh sách kiểu đăng ký ở
trường đấy ngày hôm sau tôi xuống hàn
Thuận 800 chỉ vì có một loạt các bạn
đăng ký vào các bạn ơi kém có giận 3
điểm nhưng + 3,5 điểm hơn tôi đã rời
chưa
chịu em bé đây tôi thi ở nhờ tôi được cả
cái từ nhằm điểm 24 hai từ điểm rưỡi có
tôi toàn 888 kiểu thế thôi Ừ nhưng mà
Mấy bạn kia được cộng điểm lên cao chịu
vậy chịu mày
nói chung à
Tôi chưa kể mấy ông vụ đấy Đó là tôi là
dân tôi không phải tôi không phải là dân
Hà Nội gốc nhưng mà nói cho tôi sinh ra
lớn lên đây thì không được cộng điểm nào
nhưng mà tôi khá là beng các bạn
ngay hôm trước đấy là tôi chửi mày ông
Dân Hà Nội gốc ở cửa về cái vụ cộng điểm
bà các bạn ngoại tình các bạn ấy bị
thiệt thòi mà các bạn hiển nhiên phải
được cộng nhưng hư thứ cho đến ngày hôm
sau tôi khi mà thấy mình trong về danh
sách 800 người thứ hai người
được cộng không được cộng điểm nào là
tôi một đứa nữa tôi ngay cả hai đứa đến
bị loạn tất cả những người gọi lại đều
đều được cộng điểm điều vãi
ạ Bây giờ giả sử 800 người ấy 799 8
người đều là dân tỉnh nhà
à Xong rồi Nhiều người được cộng điểm
cao thì sau đó vài ngày rồi biết được
cái phút về cái vụ là là chỉ cần làm xin
làm con nuôi của thương binh liệt sĩ
hoặc cả xin xin kiểu xin cái hộ khẩu gì
đó của họ hàng xa không ở ngoại thành có
như được cộng điểm đó trong năm của tôi
nằm mà chỗ dễ kiếm điểm cộng cực vía vụ
đấy nó có rượu nhà nhưng đại khái nó như
thế dành cho thành ra là chỗ
Ừ nó nó thành kiến cái việc thiện hạ học
đứa tôi bao nhiêu trò đùa đấy
Ê mày không biết vụ này không chỉ cần
xin cái giấy xác nhận là con nuôi của
thương binh liệt sĩ ông được cộng 1 điểm
anh về anh ra chị yêu nhà thì chạy tiền
thôi Để tiền đấy mà đông trên Bây giờ kí
vào cái giấy xong cậu điều dễ
nha À và thôi à chị học vốn vốn với tôi
ngay từ trước khi thi tôi không chú
trọng về cái được à Phải thì các thứ thứ
và đương nhiên mình vẫn cố gắng hết
Ừ mình vẫn cố gắng hết sức để mà thi
nhau mà ý tôi là tôi không cậu thực sự
là kéo không thi được đại học thì nó
không phải là chuyện gì đó quá khinh
khủng bởi vì à với tôi con điểm gì ạ
khi vào đại học thì vẫn chẳng qua là đấy
là là 45 mình sẽ ăn ngủ chơi ở đâu Gần
như thế Tự nhiên là gặp các thầy cô tốt
thì mình sẽ ngoài có kiến thức mình sẽ
được truyền cảm hứng nhưng mà nhưng mà
thực sự thì nó vẫn đối tôi không quan
trọng lắm không nặng nề lắm nhiều bạn
bởi vì a nó đánh tôi nó không không Tạm
các lực gì mấy về mấy cái vụ đấy Yêu cầu
là phải chi thi trưởng điểm phải thì Vân
Vân như thế nào đấy À tôi ngay từ lúc
đầu với ngắm chỗ chẳng cần nhắm vào Bách
Khoa làm gì cả hãy tới thế
cái về thời đại học và thương thứ còn
tôi không nặng nề về vấn đề lắm à
là một vấn đề kháng nghị cả và năm đấy
cũng không đăng bài mới về báo với cả em
có khi tôi tí thôi phải cắt cái đoạn
video không biết đâu về sau chính mình
và mấy giống kiểu Linh ka chứ mình K Hồi
trước nói câu thôi tiền mua được điểm
rất mạnh lên chửi được rồi về sau bị có
vụ cố đẩy thật rồi cẩu Tuy nhiên Linh ka
không mua nhà nó có vụ vô là dùng tiền
để mua được thật lúc đấy gì ạ mọi người
lại quay ra bờ đó là chữ sai Linh ka rồi
dân mạng vừa sáng sợ lắm nhưng mà người
đang rực lên hội
Ừ đấy thì ra đấy ở là lý do tội không
muốn mình có thể nổi nhưng mà tội không
muốn cực kì nổi buồn là mình à là người
à
A gọi như nào chất lượng hơn số lượng
dồi số lượng đông quá sao về sau có
những người kéo ùa theo mình vừa theo có
thể bảo là đã kiểu à
anh quý mình hay thích mình với Vân gì
Thì đó về sau mình mà có gì đó sai còn
nhiều sẽ bóc phốt mình hay gió chẳng hạn
à Dạ những người cẩu thế nguy hiểm
ở trên mạng mình mà nổi lên từ dẫn mạnh
ấy và đặc biệt ở còn ăn tiền với Mạnh
chẳng hạn về sau mình sẽ chết rồi dân
mạng cũng có người già thích người ta
vui giờ chúng mình đấy do tôi không muốn
làm liên quan đến tiền bạc đã biết mấy
cái làm vì đam mê như thế này bởi vì nếu
mà làm vì đam mê mà động ở trên bàn ngay
thì về sau chính cái tiền bạc đấy phải
giết chết đam mê mình nó ảnh hưởng đến
mình
inbox qua Facebook em nhé
Vì sao anh ờ anh tạo cái làng chơi ma
sói đấy cho trí sinh viên của anh ngồi
trước bởi vì anh từng nói là sinh viên
của anh ở truồng gì nữa
sau 1 tuần chỉ học 5 buổi mỗi buổi chỉ
có bốn tiếng thường là buổi sáng và buổi
chiều thôi thì thời gian kiểu dạng là ở
với nhau khá ít ngắn ngủi một lớp thì
chỉ có hai mấy người cũng không có khuôn
viên trường để không có cả
không một quả không Có có không không có
căng tin không có kiểu thư viện như là
thành là kiểu sinh viên của tôi Đúng
kiểu đến học xong đi về anh ra ở chỗ sự
đoàn kết giữa các sinh viên này nhau giờ
thấp Nhưng hãy để tôi muốn tạo ra một
cái sân chơi cho sinh viên hồi nãy tôi
cam tạo câu lạc bộ lập trình Nếu mày
không có biết thì để cho các bạn coi là
bộ lập trình tự nhiên để đấy Học rồi
không có chơi bời trong đấy à Nhưng mà
còn có một nhóm sinh viên thôi nữa thôi
kiểu cho các sinh viên giao lưu và chơi
nha và chơi cả với tôi nữa là kiểu là
chúng tôi thường ai tổ chức boardgame
vào tối cuối tuần nữa nhắn thì nó vui ở
chỗ nó làm chơi là phụ thôi Quan trọng
là chúng ta kiểu mỗi cuối tuần chúng ta
sẽ có một cái cớ gì đó để mà hàng tuần
người ta gặp nhau giao lưu xe mà có cái
gì mới không ạ thì cái nhóm của tôi phát
triển thì cũng ăn được à hơn cũng tầm 5
năm rồi từ từ Thời đấy và gần gần như ở
chủ nhật nào cũng cũng cũng có kèo
a74 dùng từ gần như ở vì cái hồi rạch
thì đương nhiên là không không có kẹo
rồi hoặc cả hôm mà cực kì 10 trả thôi
còn đâu à ở đâu thì vẫn vẫn đi con thức
của
khi ăn mừng 10 nhìn ra tôi thấy Thực ra
tôi khá vui khi mà kênh có thể lên
ngưỡng đấy nhưng mà nửa vui nửa thực Lạ
thấy nó hơi bị nó bị con số quá tất cả
sao bởi vì à Thực ra tôi do tôi đang
truy tìm công ty thấy là nhiều ông bấm
vào Ấn theo dõi cho vụ mà anh hiểu
Sprite đấy cho vui thôi nhận chị ở trong
đấy không biết là bao nhiêu nick Clone
nữa đấy Nhưng mà thực sự thì mấy ông xem
ấy thì số lượng người xem thực tế bây
giờ hai mới thử cho biết không biết được
là hai mấy đấy có chỉ ra hay không mọi
việc đấy mấy ông thấy chủ yếu bình luận
tương tác thì gặp chỉ có tầm chục người
anh cần thế
cho tôi Tôi từng nói ngay từ hội đầu đi
dạy mở lớp dạy thêm mấy ông rồi tôi
không quan trọng với số lượng lắm nên là
nên là cậu không quan tâm mấy mấy cái
vấn đề số lắm nhà đương nhiên sẽ vui vui
Hiệp vẫn vui không thể nói là chê được
nhưng mà lắm Chị à vì sau tôi tôi muốn
và về sau thực ra kênh này của tôi về
sau sẽ là sẽ là inox nữa thì về sau tôi
lại muốn ví dụ dại như này có thể sẽ
chuyên sâu mà thực ra đã có thể số lượng
lấy xem hơi ít ngờ về sau tôi hi vọng và
gia đình những cái á ở những cây sản
phẩm này Cái Vlog đầu tiên để nhận thì
mong được ủng hộ hơn cả dễ hiểu không đi
cái số lượng 10.000 người theo dõi chảy
nghĩa gì cả đúng không
còn phí lót đấy bởi vì Năm sau tôi sẽ
mua cả iPhone thì quay ổn hơn này mua
gimbal này mua cả mày ghi âm này để mà
cậu ghi âm tiếng này như bồ rồi mà cậu
giữ liền mà quay phim các thứ thế này
đấy
đấy và cái cách quay của tôi đương nhiên
cháu vì sao tôi sẽ học cái đít rồi nhờ
ai đó ta tự mình làm hột để mà kiểu
chỉnh sửa các thứ thứ để mà gì mà cậu ạ
Ừ cái Vlog của tôi về sau nó sẽ hướng
như nào sẽ là kiểu một buổi tôi đi đâu
đó mà tôi sẽ nói cái Cái kiểu suy nghĩ
mình so với bụi đấy hoặc những cái gì đó
tôi nghĩa là nó sẽ là một chủ đề đó Cậu
là một kiểu là Cường một buổi đi chơi
vui thôi cậu như thế nhưng mà theo góc
nhìn của một dân công nghệ thì sẽ như
thế nào chẳng hạn thế một cái cậu một
cái tên mang thiên hướng thư giãn đúng
cậu thế bởi vì tôi thấy là gần đây
gần đây là cậu ở góc làm việc với sao
thì chẳng có gì sau bí chủ đề quá đủ
kiểu luôn nhưng mà Thì tôi là tôi xem
mấy cái kênh của mấy cái anh đi du lịch
xong rồi anh ấy cũng cũng hiểu à
cho anh đấy có quay lại và nói cảm nghĩ
mình các thứ thứ
mỗi cái truyền đi thấy khá hay nó kiểu
khá nhẹ nhàng hợp với đi ngủ hồi xem
trước khi đi ngủ ấy cái mục tiêu của tôi
về sau nó sẽ hết không phải là một cái
kênh nó mang tính chất khá nặng nề đỡ
nhưng về sau thì là tôi sẽ nói một vài
con điểm suy nghĩ cá nhân mình có giống
như là tôi sẽ tham khảo của bạn của anh
Vinh Xô lại chẳng hạn Anh Vinh bên vợ ấy
thì thỉnh thoảng sẽ có vài kinh nghiệm
vài cái video khá nghiêm túc để nó suy
nghĩ mình nhưng mà chủ yếu là sẽ khá thư
giãn đấy Ờ
ở hà thư giãn heo cửa một cái giải trí
gì đó anh đấy thì có cái độ Duyên riêng
người không nói tôi không nghĩ là tôi sẽ
trở nên hài hước được như mình anh đấy
nhưng mà ý tôi là theo một góc nhìn của
dân công nghệ sẽ nha sẽ chẳng hạn thế
còn nên tham khảo của mình anh khác
giống như kiểu anh tôi đi cô dạo hay
không Tôi sợ nó khi mà xem nhiều của mấy
anh khác nữa thì sẽ bị gọi là
sau
khi mà mặc định mà Mấy ông xe mấy kiểu
gì mà ông chẳng học hỏi đúng không Dễ
thương không phải xem kiểu dạng thôi
không Không nhớ gì trong đầu rồi gì cũng
sẽ nhớ một tí lòng đầu và khi học hỏi
thế đôi khi mà
khi đôi khi ở mấy ông sẽ Cậu bệnh chưa
Không có cái không có cái kiểu riêng của
mình mà là cậu sẽ bị cắt nhạc mỗi người
một tí ra nó vẫn không say bà bản chất
là vẫn học hỏi nên học họ nhưng mà ý tôi
là là tôi sẽ học hỏi những anh khác
không phải là anh dân không phải ở dân
công nghệ thì tôi sẽ học hỏi còn những
về anh mà đang làm dân công nghệ rồi Tôi
không muốn thực sự biết được Còn mấy anh
đấy Đang làm gì tự thử bởi vì ạ đó Nó
kiểu mình ở dân trong ngành với nhau mà
bây giờ tự nhiên mình mình ăn gần như à
có nhiều người sẽ cho là ăn cắp ý tưởng
của nhau cắt cái cách cách cách của đấy
phong cách của nhau không lên nhà tôi
nghĩa là tôi sẽ có một phong cách riêng
bạn có thể tham khảo của những cái anh
khác không phải dân công nghệ thông tin
thì được
Ừ thì mình sẽ một cái thằng Dân công
nghệ thông tin tình cảm của những người
khác còn nếu là dân công nghệ thông tin
vừa ăn cắp của dân công nghệ thông tin
nữa rồi Đúng kiểu không nên đúng không
Tôi nghĩ là gì thế
anh em bé ông nào đề xuất cái kênh nhà
cho cậu cái nào hay hay thì tôi có thể
tôi sẽ xem thông Thảo
anh hoặc là tôi đang nói chuyện nhưng mà
thằng đa cấp này cách màu cái chữ tôi
không hỏi đấy
chắn ở Hôm nào tôi sẽ quay kiểu tôi đi
làm ở công ty sẽ như nào với Vân có chứ
Chỉ sợ lúc đấy à Lúc mà hồi đầu cái gì
Chẳng ra rất nhiều video về lí tưởng
không biết được rồi bắt đầu hạn dần đi
nhưng mà Thậm chí thậm chí có một cái
hay này tôi nghĩ là có vài anh có thể
chưa làm đó là tôi sẽ còn à Còn bao gồm
cả một ngày tôi đi dậy sẽ như thế nào
nói cho hạ thế
Anh chán thế tôi nghĩa là chưa có ai làm
vụ đấy đâu bởi vì những người làm dân
công nghệ ở da người đã không biết giận
đúng không Đúng nhỉ áo phông số những
người tôi biết thì chưa có ai đi làm đi
dậy cả một đời đi làm hay là có dạy Công
Nghệ Thông Tin có nhưng mà chỉ vậy thôi
không có kiểu vừa đi làm mới dậy
có ai
ở Sapa có người thì cũng có nhưng mà
cũng không làm vlog này thì mình mình đỡ
bị cạnh tranh rồi
có thầy làm việc đó không không không
lên cao học hay Thạc sĩ không cho ngành
này
khi gà tôi từng trả lời mấy cái hộp này
rồi đó là kiểu à
anh không không quan trọng với bằng cấp
Nhưng mà nếu mà về sau muốn làm cho công
ty nhà nước hay là
đi đầu thổi Đúng là nên có những cái gì
đó chứng chỉ bằng cấp gì đó thì về các
bạn nó sẽ nó sẽ tăng đến mức lương của
ông lên tăng độ uy tín nên rồi Nhiều
người vẫn thích kiểu nhìn vào cái giấy
tờ đấy nhưng mà về chung với thương Cửa
Ông làm ở công ty nước ngoài hay là làm
công ty tư nhân bình thường thì ra nó
không có tấm bằng cấp luôn
Ê cái xong đi dạy giống như tôi nữa thì
đúng là kiểu Nghe Bằng đấy bây giờ thử
nói à cả
Xin chào Tôi may ra có cái mác là cậu đã
từng 35 đi dậy và làm trưởng bộ môn khi
còn có thể là nó con oa một tí để mà
mình đứng lớp chứ Giả sử cậu đứng lớp mà
không có cả mạn không có kẻ bằng để họp
với người người ta lúc đầu người ta nghe
có thể người ta sẽ Trọng Nghĩa này thằng
nó đâu đó không muốn nghe chẳng hạn thế
Thế bây giờ giả sử tôi và giáo sư của
các hư thứ sẽ dạy trực tiếp buổi học này
nghe nó oai hơn hẳn với các bạn thì nó
vẫn có gì thôi nghĩ là nó tín hẳn thế
anh Dũng lại đi dậy đó có kênh đấy nữa ừ
cạnh tranh quá
à à
em chưa biết phải niệm mà lo
I my life
dạ mà vẽ về cuộc đời tôi như thế nào
ở ga tôi có đang suy nghĩ về kể về cuộc
đời tôi có đấy Tôi muốn làm từ Block mà
nhưng nhưng mà
cụ thể nếu mà tôi về sau tôi biết sách
hỏi cả làm cái gì đó về kể về cái kiểu
đời tôi tốt hơn Thấy Tí nữa Khánh
có khá nhiều người sẽ chủ
anh đồng cảm nghĩ rồi nhưng mà nhiều
người thấy nhìn thôi Anh mắt cũng khác
hơn rồi kìa bởi vì theo như những cái
người bạn mà tôi từng Chỉ cái qua về
cuộc đời thôi
trải qua những cái gì người ta nhìn tôi
ánh mắt khác lắm à
Ừ tự nhiên là về bạn mình nhìn như họ
cũng không chế chắc thì mấy mình nếu mà
con gà có người cũng khóc cảm động có
ngày nó sao khóc nhờ rất sẵn là cuộc đời
tôi tính ra thì nó không
vì nó không em đẹp để cho lắm
nó nó giống như phim hơn dùng thử phim
Cũng đúng đấy một vì tôi cảm thấy cuộc
sống thôi nó thăng trầm Đủ Kiểu nó như
phim cũng đúng em không có tưởng tượng
không à
bộ phim bản chất phim tại hỏi thủng trái
tim này và cái nó cao trào lên xuống mà
có rất nhiều về cài cái nó nó đúng kiểu
dạng như ở mấy ông tưởng tượng nó chỉ có
chính tìm em ạ Đấy thì thì tôi lại dính
buồn cười như thế cậu ạ
Vì sao về sau tôi viết sách 21 vẽ cuộc
đời làm phim rồi nghĩ mới làm được
em về cuộc đời tôi Tôi khẳng định nó
không tẩy ngạt thở
cơ hội thăng trầm Bãi Thượng luôn được
như bây giờ
cho ví dụ là
cơm một tôi không có bạn bè Đẵng một
thôi à
em có một tôi ở thằng đầu gấu được hả em
biết mấy bộ đâu đã không hỏi có một đầu
gấu ờ ờ
à Xong rồi Không bạn bè ở
ở cấp 2 Thành phần 1sách vật rất nhiều
cái tôi nói chung là trí nhớ mình cũng
tốt nữa mình sẽ vẽ được cái vẽ được cái
đấy
Bây giờ ngồi đợi ông nhìn mà tôi non
choẹt vào tối Hiền lại chưa Như thế nhau
hồi bé thì cá hồi hồi cấp 1 lần đầu với
dễ mà ông chỉ cần bọn nó yếu ớt mà không
đầy cái không anh đón bạn nó khác rồi Có
gì đâu
Thôi em đầu gấu nhưng mà tôi hạ hai đi
thích bắt nạt người khác nha Màu đầu có
hơi thở chuyện nữa tối hay đánh bọn nó
thôi vì bọn trẻ con bỏ thường anh nói
những cái câu cậu từng ai trêu bố mẹ cái
gì đó là nạn thì tôi cứ
cậu xao động nên bố mẹ mình thì mình
đánh võ như vậy thế biết bao nhiêu cái
bản kiểm điểm rồi bao nhiêu đơn vị
button trước thưởng có tính thuế
trả lời Thấy có bồ chưa Nó quay cũng
chán vãi
nhà nhà thờ
cà phê các bạn dẫn tự học chẳng qua là
Khi họ trung tâm thì ông sẽ cảm thấy an
tâm hơn phần nào và thực tế là ông vẫn
vẫn phải tự học với mình chiếc nhẫn cái
thứ thứ lý tưởng nhất mà tôi thấy không
phải bài toán ở việc và ông học ở đâu mà
ông học với ai vì với cá nhân tôi thì ạ
thì có người học đồng hành cùng Giống
nhờ hộ ngay hôm qua thôi vừa mới đăng ký
học piano ạ
tôi tôi nghĩa là tay của tôi lại từ hồi
cấp 1 là một thằng đầu gấu gì
từ hồi cấp 1 của tôi ở phía tôi làm việc
nhà nhiều em chân tay tôi khỏe nghe tôi
ở tuổi dậu khỏe hơn mày cái thằng được
nữa nhưng mà
à à càng lớn lên thì tôi cảnh sáng làm
gì cả anh ra chân tay mềm nhũn như dầu
tay thôi chỗ rất là thon gọn theo như
nhiều bạn nữ vào cái đẹp hả anh mềm mại
trừ khi đó nên Thành A Tôi cũng muốn
được cho có tận dụng để bàn tay nghệ sĩ
này tới tôi bảo tôi rất thích tận dụng
với cái á
à à
Ừ tôi rất thích tận dụng mấy cái cậu à
ngược đĩa mình thì biến ưu điểm rõ ràng
một thằng con trai kiểu dạng là tay mềm
các cử gà là cá nhân thì sẽ có thể bị
chê không be mình tận dụng nó bằng cách
mình mình đi đánh đàn này cho biết mình
nó bay Nghệ sĩ hãy hiểu thế cho cả hoặc
là mấy ông biết massage hả tôi được biết
rồi tay mềm mại với ông sẽ học quá xa
này bạn gái sẽ thích nó này Khi bữa trưa
từng massage cho cô nó cả mẹ để mà xin
tiền đi lễ Mỗi tội à anh làm nửa chừng
mọi ngủ thôi toàn quên đưa tiền cho mình
cài vãi
Ừ có thì bây giờ tôi học đi học đánh đàn
piano rồi còn nếu mà ghi ta là sẽ đi
hỏng tay nữa
thời gian tối thiểu tối chiều hay tối đa
nghỉ tối thiểu thì thì thì thời các cân
nhắc thời việc và là ông
Ừ Ông học hỏi được con học hỏi thêm nữa
không và đương nhiên là nên làm xong hết
những cái mà người ta đã gọi giao cho
ông đã trước khi ông nghỉ việc nên là
như thế thế thôi
không nghỉ hai tiếng Anh là đủ anh thực
tế là tôi nghĩ tiếng Anh nó đã gần như
là
em làm như lạ Ờ nó bao quát khá nhiều
rồi còn nếu mà ông thực sự là ông ông có
thể học thêm nữa thì càng tốt nhưng mà
ông Nghĩa Ông phải nghĩ và toàn là ông
đã tận dụng hết được chưa Ví dụ ở sự ông
học tiếng Anh sau mà không tận dụng hết
họ thêm với những cái khác chưa chứ đừng
có ham số lượng quá mừng chất lượng nói
ít họ ông phải nói cho ông phải có mục
đích rõ ràng đã
gái đa số của các bạn bây giờ này đó là
kiểu ở các bạn ơi lịch học kín này Vân
này vẫn muốn đi làm Vân Nói chung là các
bạn một cân bằng được cái đấy gần như
các bạn chẳng thời gian nghỉ đấy ngủ khó
đừng nói việc nó đi chơi rồi thì cái này
Thực ra là tuổi trẻ khi mày không phải
đánh đổi như thế đúng nghĩa Thế không
phải đánh đổi thời gian ngủ thì ông ngồi
cày hay đủ thứ nhưng mà hơi bị ông nên
tư duy đơn giản thôi đó đi thực tập thì
bạn chắc là khi thực tập Ông vẫn học hỏi
mà nó ngon nếu mà ông học chúng ông học
và làm đúng ngành không ạ thì nó không
sao cả cho ông tôi vẫn khuyên mấy ông cọ
có nên được đi thực tập cho đừng có họp
xong rồi mới bắt đầu đi thì nó về thì
các bạn đi khác đi trước cũng như ông sẽ
cảm thấy ra cậu nó sẽ khó khăn khi xin
để trả Thế cũng như là là vừa học vừa đi
thực tập thì ông lại có hứng học hơn
thật À thế à Bà
à mà đương nhiên nào đúng là ông phải
cánh đội thời gian ngủ Ấy không sẽ khá
mệt
Ừ nhưng mà Chính vì thế cũng nên đừng có
nên nhiều bạn thì xác định là vừa học
vừa đi làm và làm ở đây là nói chuyện
làm kiếm tiền chứ không phải làm để cho
học học kinh nghiệm Thầy cha à bạn đấy
Bị cài quá ra kiểu bị cho giống kiểu đôi
khi làm fulltime ấy sẽ hiểu rõ là mệt
với ông nên xác định theo ngành này thì
xác định lúc đầu là đi học tập không có
lương và đơn hoặc cả trợ cấp ít chứ như
này ra là nó mệt đấy Sao mệt
không
Ừ thế này đúng kéo đổ cái nhận ông phải
cao lắm rồi không biết khuyên ông ạ Bạn
chờ tôi mua từng mua khá nhiều đến bây
giờ tôi nếu không thấy hai cái tát đầu
tôi đang thêm không Chị Hai cái RAM thôi
mua mấy cái buổi khoa học này tôi mới
xem đến buổi Thứ 5 này hãy sẵn Thế chị
thuận lợi không Xem có thứ kiến nick cho
ông và khả năng tự học không tốt thì tổ
chẳng ý kiến gì cả
trong cái môi trường mà cậu tốt thì nó
cải thiện mình khá nhiều nghe tôi nghĩ à
mấy ông đi thực tập Càng sớm thì nó
chẳng sao cả tốt thôi Nó còn có thêm
động lực để học Nếu được ý nghĩa rất là
phải học xong rồi mình nên đi
Ừ nhưng mà
cho nên vẫn nên xác định thực tập là
không phải bị đồng tiền mạnh thì mới làm
được
em 28 tuổi đi làm ở công ty mà công việc
nhàn quá thì sao ờ chính câu của tự hỏi
để mà
anh tự đánh giá rồi ông ạ thì đó là là
ông Ông cảm thấy là nó có vấn đề không ạ
gần đây ở đây nó sẽ là ông ông nghĩ à
Ông cách giải quyết của ông như thế nào
giải quyết là theo cờ là nghỉ việc để
làm cùng chỗ khác là nó có liệu cổ liệu
nó có chắc chắn là sẽ ổn Đấy không còn
nếu mà không thì ông sẽ phải suy nghĩ
việc là ông sẽ vẫn phải giữ được đấy và
ông sẽ làm những cái thứ khác để mà kiểu
học học thêm những cái thứ mới cải thiện
hay gì đó còn nếu mà những công việc đấy
ngoài việc nhàn ra thì nó nó kiểu dạng
là nó còn phá là áp lực hay là à dùng từ
áp lực Không đúng ngàn
à à Không ngàn đi thì hỏng có áp lực
kinh tế hãy Vân thì đúng là không phải
cân nhắc về việc nghỉ nhưng mà luôn bài
toán nghỉ là ông phải xác định chắc chắn
cái công việc khác nó ổn hơn nhé Trông
bánh mì chứ không phải thức đúng đắn
nghỉ rồi thành thất nghiệp giữ trái
khuya làm thế Cả ông ạ nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà còn nếu ở nhà đương nói chung
mà vẫn đủ để sống và vân cũng không phải
lăn tăn việc đấy Thì ông nên kiếm thêm
những cái thứ khác để mà kiểu mình làm
thôi thì nó sẽ đỡ nhà nữa ngọn
ở tuổi trẻ Thực ra tôi vẫn không khiêm
béo mà lên ngàn quá Nói chung trước 30
tuổi thì ông vẫn lên cày II cày đây là
cây không phải cái tiền nhiều ông vẫn
quan điểm cái tiền cày đây cái kinh
nghiệm cái rất nhiều thứ
em học hỏi rất nhiều thứ bởi vì a trước
30 tuổi Tôi vẫn quan điểm mà mình vẫn có
thể phát triển bản thân được tốt nhất Nó
sau 30 thì ông luôn có cái tôi ông luôn
có cái độ bảo thủ hiểu Khi mong nhận
được đủ lượng kiến thức của ông sẽ có vị
giới thiệu là bảo thủ hơn ông sẽ khó
tiếp thu cái nước hơn được người khó vỏ
thêm Vân thì thì lúc đấy Lúc đấy thì
thực ra lúc 30 tuổi ông mới bắt đầu mới
cài được đấy bởi vì Ông là người có kinh
nghiệm rồi ông lên về cái tầm nó rồi thì
ông lúc đấy ông ấy kiếm được nhiều tiền
hơn từ những cái kinh nghiệm của trước
năm 30 tuổi ông đã gây dựng được nên là
năm bạn trước năm 30 tuổi ông nên cài có
kinh nghiệm vì thế ý của tôi nó không
nên học hỏi học được những đề gì có thể
học khi học học là nhiều có tốt cho thứ
Chớ đừng Nhưng mà đừng học loãng nhé Mà
học kiểu học à
bộ chuyên sâu về một cái này cái gì đó
Vân này thì thì khi mà năm bao nhiêu
tuổi lúc nào cũng
Ừ đúng mà ông cậu thực sự là ông có thể
bùng nổ được Ông tìm được những công
việc không còn lúc đấy không nên là kiểu
trị nhân đạo này làm cái chức vụ què nữa
Mong phải lên lên được mấy ngưỡng nào đó
Chị nói là làm quản lý không hẳn đúng
nhiều người không phù hợp với ngành quản
lý nhóm mình thì tôi ở lên được hẳn cái
cao su nê ô hay gì đó một cái tầm gió
bởi những cái kinh nghiệm đúc kết từ
trước Nếu nghỉ cho thì lúc đấy ông kiếm
được lúc đấy mấy là lúc không kiếm đi
từ trước bây giờ ông bảo là năm hai mươi
mấy tuổi Ông ấy có một tí nghiệm làm sao
không cài được nhiều tiền không thể cài
được nhiều tiền lúc này Nói thẳng như
thế ông ông chưa có kinh nghiệm thì ông
không có nơi nào khiến ông về cây tiền
từ việc kể cả kể cả kinh doanh luôn
không thành có kinh nghiệm gì để ông cầy
ông cùng lắm là ông cầy trong cái trong
cái khoảng thời gian này là một lần
trong ngày lập trình này thì ông cài Cửa
Ông đổi tuổi trẻ ra tiền này hoa cà
ngang vai ngang khác thì giống như thế
nào ạ
có thể thao thì bây giờ con cầy được này
quá sức với cây này hoặc là ngành về à
công nghệ sĩ à giống kiểu à Ở người mẫu
này thì mai ông cây được trước năm 70
tuổi bởi vì nó với ông chẳng cần này có
kinh nghiệm thì cả ông đúng nghĩa là ông
ông dùng cái nhan sắc hay Vân dùng cái
nghệ thuật ông làm bao tiền thôi
à còn đâu về còn về chung ấy những cái
nhàng làm bìa nhàng quá hậu trí óc nhưng
mình không ạ thì mình phải mình phải học
hỏi trong cái quả để ra này giống như
ngay tôi rồi Tôi vẫn đang đi học đàn này
thôi tôi còn muốn học thêm và Vân gì đó
trước năm 30 tuổi
đồ án tốt nghiệp ở trường cũ trường cũ
tôi thấy mà
Em có phải có cái xác nhận tốt nghiệp đi
thực tập đi khá nhiều trường làm cho đấy
để mà
cô Nguyễn Thị Sinh viên đi đi thường gặp
tôi
tự học PR Fe không biết cái gì
Ừ chắc không cần phải cô đâu nhỉ
I tr s
nối gì à
ở trong cái ngành Công nghệ thông tin ở
chung là chỉ luôn nên biết một tí về lập
trình thì càng tốt chỉ cần lập trình cơ
bản thôi nhưng mà cần lấy biết một tí ấp
trình chị tốt Em sẽ khiến mọi thứ đơn
giản hơn và tư duy hiểm sẽ thay đổi
anh không không cần nên cái lập trình
đấy vẫn chỉ cần lập trình cơ bản cũng
không cần phải làm ra đồng hồ phần mềm
thì đâu nghe nói cho vợ chỉ cần biết
được lập trình như thế nào để về sau
giải quyết vấn đề cờ ông nói chuyện được
người ta không khinh ông không nói
chuyện được với nó trình viên mà người
ta cũng kiểu không phải cậu Hải chả biết
cái gì mà nói vừa rồi anh cảm thấy rằng
ạ
khích luôn mà ông xin không đưa người ta
quá người đã sẵn sàng trong việc thôi
nha với điều kiện người ta thấy tư duy
không có phải làm việc chứ không phải
phá việc người ta thì thoải mái thôi
không sao cả ông có nhu cầu cầu tiến thì
chẳng ai cả đông cả sẵn Còn nếu mà công
ty nào mà không nhận ông ấy công ty chia
thôi hãy suy nghĩ luôn suy nghĩ gì hết
kể cả trong mối quan hệ yêu đương đến
giờ vẫn suy nghĩ là như thế
Tôi bảo rồi đôi khi cậu hẹn hò yêu đương
nó không khác gì ông đang đi phỏng vấn
cả ông tự tin vào
cô bạn thân mình là người ta không nhận
là người ra thiệt không phải lỗi của
mình Mình sẽ tìm người hiểu à
anh nhìn được cái cái giá trị của mình
chứ không phải nên chạy theo gì đó Nói
vẫn vở thấy thằng Hòa tôi vẫn sẽ chạy
theo nhưng mà chạy theo chỉ để chứng
minh là mình ổn Thật
A và khi mà chứng minh xong rồi họ vẫn
cảm thấy không nhìn được mình thì thôi
buông thôi đến lúc đấy là mình không có
gì Nuối Tiếc à mình không ân hận thì mua
Ok chưa
ừ ừ
ở trong quá trình học không đi thực tập
Ừ rồi Tốt nghiệp xong đi phỏng vấn luôn
phe sơ được không ở
cái này trong ngành Công nghệ thông tin
này nó khó đấy Kiểu gì ông cũng nên có
một vài kinh nghiệm thì đó không thì khi
ra ngoài ông chỉ cầm cái bằng thì ông
thì lại ông đối chọn với những người
khác nó khó cực
từ trước khi bằng sâu sắc là ông có quen
biết gì đó còn không cho xóa luôn
mà không đi thực tập Nhờ mày ông cũng
nên làm cái sản phẩm cái đoán kiểu nghe
thấy ông có cái khỏe đấy
hôm hôm rồi nhỉ
Ừ có gì mày ông à thắc mắc gì thì cho
xem vài buổi hôm trước rồi tôi cũng sẽ
tâm sự thì ta ở Hôm nay có vài câu hỏi
là từ mấy hôm trước tôi cũng trả lời đấy
tôi còn đang sợ việc trả lời lặp đi lặp
lại thế Có khi tôi rơi rụng mất cái câu
trả lời của tôi nó không còn cho Suốt
được cái trở về sau tôi sẽ làm một cái
kiểu à
cho cậu một cái chạm à thôi trước tôi
định thế rồi làm cái tôi sẽ ngồi trên
cốt cho mày ông cậy à Like cốt luôn này
mày không xem là mày kiểu dạng mà nó
khái niệm Vision
faq nhỉ
A Di Đà
xe Vision asquith Trần Nghĩa là những
câu hỏi thường gặp và tôi sẽ trả lời với
diễn chạy con boss tự động trả lời luôn
những câu hỏi thưa thường mà được hỏi
thế cho mấy ông nó sẽ khá hay hiệu chuẩn
như thế
Em nhìn anh giao tiếp tốt đâu ạ Mình
đừng tham gia công ty đa cấp để được như
rồi nhé nhớ tớ không phím cách mấy ông
như thế mà tôi khuyến khích mà ông phía
trước này vẫn là gì có ngoài trả lời hộ
tôi với ông nhớ tin trả lời câu này rồi
đó là
có cách nào để giao tiếp tốt cây có
người nóng tương tự giống như hồi trước
tôi từng nói mấy ông đó là cách nào để
mà gõ máy tính nhanh hơn đi
em có mào nhớ cái câu trả lời được không
ạ
chỉ việc đấy cho tôi đang thấy nó hơi bị
tôi sợ là nhớ dậy đôi khi hơi khó quá
nhiều bạn không theo được cái việc là là
sợ các bạn bị phụ thuộc quá Thôi nha là
cũng hay đến bây giờ có nhiều bạn vẫn
đang ngủ nhiều bạn vẫn cốt theo phong
cách riêng của bạn đấy đôi khi nó sai
thì cũng không ở đúng lắm đâu nhưng mà
gần như là
các bạn đấy vẫn Em chịu khó mình mỏi
thêm lại có thử ý dài chứ không bị phụ
thuộc quá theo kiểu là tôi cốc nào mấy
ông ấy chưa cũng như thế gì thì sẽ bị
chỗ bị tư duy 9 thì ra là không không tự
phát triển đi 01
ờ ờ ờ cái cách để mở giao tiếp tốt mà gõ
máy tính nhanh đó Ông nói chuyện với con
gái nhiều và nói chuyện thực ra không
phải mỗi con gái rồi nói chuyện với tất
cả mọi người nhiều là thoải mái thì được
nhiều Do Tiên mong sẽ cải thiện thôi bây
giờ này thôi có thể lưu đầu cũng sẽ rất
nhạt nhưng ông phải biết được là
có cây cây lý do khiến nó tôi nói được
mạnh miệng như bây giờ đúng nghĩa bởi vì
giờ thứ nhất ở Tôi tin là tôi đang nói
đúng thôi đã
đã từng chạy nhiều ra từng bị che nhiều
nhờ tôi biết được là tôi bị chê cái gì
Vân tôi biết mình tốt mạnh điểm gì yếu
điểm gì tại Vân để mà khiến cho mình à
nhà mình cần biết được mình sẽ
chỉ cần khắc phục cái gì cần
ê cần à nhấn mạnh cầm nổi bật cái ưu
điểm mình lên nó ngoại Vân thế thôi
Ừ ông nói chuyện nhiều mọi người Kiểu gì
không sẽ cẩu
dự án đương nhiên nói chuyện Ở đây là
ông vẫn nên tinh tế một tí ông để ý xem
mà những người ấy có cái điểm gì hay để
mình học hỏi hai có điểm gì hay ở khiến
cho mình thích nói chuyện với họ hơn
chẳng hạn trả nợ thế
đã có nhiều người tôi quen họ biết được
họ tẻ nhạt họ biết họ ngạc nhưng họ hàng
ngày Họ vẫn làm đi làm lại những cái thứ
đấy họ có nói chuyện với bạn bè như ngày
nào họ cũng chỉ đi nói chuyện lại nói đi
nói chuyện lại với những bạn bè đấy thôi
không nói chuyện không không mở rộng mối
quan hệ hơn anh ra là họ cái cái cái
việc là khi nói chuyện với họ thì họ
cũng sẽ chỉ nói đi nói lại mình những
cái mà họ Đợi đã biết và và chị những
thứ nhỏ nhỏ xung quanh thôi họ cũng
không hỏi cũng không chiêm nghiệm khó
không ạ đã trải nghiệm nhiều hơn họ cũng
đọc thêm nhiều thứ chẳng hạn nên thấy da
họ cũng không biết nói gì thì thế đi Thế
thì khi mà ông nói đi nói lại một cái
thứ gì đó thì bị cho nhà tao đúng rồi
Thế thôi
có một phần là thời cá ở cái thần thái
có rất nhiều yếu tố nữa nhiều ông đang
hỏi nhạc thần thoại ông tốt thì có khi ở
ông khiến cho họ ông hung Hôm qua tôi
vừa lưu này nếu mà ông không ngại thì
người khác sẽ ngại thay ông coi nó hay
luôn
bởi vì cô ấy tôi đã từng đọc đúng ở
trong một cái ảnh nó hơi bị 18 cộng với
vì nó giả sử ở cậu đang đúng nghĩa mấy
cái này nó hơi bị nhảy cảm nhé Để tôi cứ
nói ra nhé Mấy ông giờ gì cũng quá 18
rồi nó là ông đang quay tay em ạ tự
nhiên có một người rồi đột nhiên mở cửa
phòng lại thì ở nhà ông thử ông sẽ ngại
không tắt máy đi lấy cái gì đó của ông
ông sẽ ở xấu hổ không ngại đúng không
thay ý thế không kiểu ông Ông không phải
tiếp tục làm như hôm qua ông nhìn nó ánh
mắt kia mày đang nhìn cái gì đấy rồi thế
rồi cậu ông chàng tỏ lo ngại ngùng ông
coi cái việc cũng đang làm một cái hư
quá hiển nhiên rồi thì nó sẽ ngại nó sẽ
tự động đóng cửa lại Ạ ạ
Ừ đấy nghĩa là nó tâm lý nghĩa là nếu mà
ông tổ là ngại thì họ nghĩ à Nó đã Họ
bắt mẽ rồi ông họ sẽ hiểu rõ sẽ nó nói
gì đó đúng không Nhưng mà ông ấy có dạng
như được mày vào mày không có cửa thử
thái độ ấy đang thử thì họ sẽ cảm thấy
họ mày ra người say rượu đang làm phiền
cái thứ mà ông có ông nhìn nhiều sẽ làm
gì đó Sao ạ Đây thế thôi
Ừ tôi không khuyên ông nên áp dụng cái
cái trường hợp vừa rồi Nhưng mà tao nói
việc cả là đôi khi đôi khi kể khi chất
kịch cái á tâm lý của ông phải vững mà
ông nghĩa vẫn đang làm đúng gì đó ông
thể đánh lại được cái tâm lý người khác
bơ nhiều người tâm lý yếu thật
ổn hơn mấy người đấy ông Phạm đã thắng
rồi tôi chơi boardgame Ma Sói đúng nghĩa
ở thế mà mấy người nhiều người bạn là
chơi ma sói phải diễn rồi chơi ma sói
phải nói dối Vân đã tôi chẳng cần tôi
nghĩa cái game bé ngoài sự luận đấy việc
ở bài toán tâm lý khá nhiều không không
không phải diễn mày đâu nhưng mà tâm lý
của ông mà ổn thì ông thể đánh lại được
đã tâm lý người khác
có rất nhiều lúc nào tôi là sói để chết
được Dân Ý
nhưng nói chuyện với con gái nhưng gần
mổ thóc thật à cái này là tâm lý chung
thôi Đấy là tôi nhiều lúc cũng chính tôi
cũng bị thế nhưng mà tôi lại không bị
thế khi tôi nói chuyện với con gái xác
định là tôi không tán bạn đấy Thì đúng
là tôi nói chuyện vững trở dạ như vừa
như bạn bè và và những bạn đấy lại thích
tôi nó hơi thở còn những vào hôm qua tôi
nói thế với thằng bạn nó là kiểu trớ
trêu là là
là con gái hay bị chung thế những bạn
con gái làm à thoải mái nói chuyện với
mình ấy thường mà bạn ấy có nhiều hòa
thượng bạn mình không không có cửa đâu
mà tán được bạn đấy đôi khi là có chồng
con có rồi tầm tuổi rồi Có thể cho con
rồi mà thấy cả thế mà bạn ấy sắp đi du
học và bạn đây đang ở nước ngoài và Văn
Trị bệnh nói chuyện thoải mái cực bạn
biết được là mình không có cửa bạn đấy
Mình không được tặng đấy hết con
Em có đau khi mà bạn ấy đang độc thân
thì đúng là bạn anh thương ai giữ ý
tưởng thứ nói chuyện tế nhị hơn khiến
mình khó bắt chuyện hơn được thật mình
khó thoải mái rồi các bạn ấy thật nhưng
mà Chính vì thế Mình phải có tâm lý ổn
hơn đoạn đấy khiến nó cuộc nói chuyện
thoải mái kiểu mình nói chuyện với những
người bạn ấy giống như ngay bây giờ này
nhà Bây giờ tôi đang nói chuyện với vài
bạn về tôi Tôi muốn rủ mày đi chơi ma
sói thôi Tôi không phải một đi yêu đương
gì cả Thì tôi cứ kiểu tin nhắn đúng
những ngày bạn cửa Ê mai đi chơi không
nữa bạn ơi lúc đó bạn sẽ dở hơi bất ngờ
rồi Tại sao mình cài đang nói chuyện
mình kiểu như bạn thân lâu lắm rồi nếu
bạn đấy nhưng mà con gái là cái này Thêm
Một Lần Nữa nói với ông khẳng định lại
là nhiều bạn tâm lý không hề vững và
trong đó có con gái con gái tâm lý không
hề vững và con gái không suy nghĩ Bằng
lý trí nên là ông nói chuyện được với
bạn đấy Cho Dù mới quen vẫn có thể nói
chuyện nhưng đã mấy năm rồi Nếu hàng ra
ở đâu rất nhiều lúc tôi nói chuyện nhắn
tin thì 10 những bạn mà cả lần đầu tiên
nó trợ luôn mà tôi nói chuyện nhưng thân
rồi ấy cả hướng vẫn được thoải mái Đúng
là lúc sau bạn ấy có thể ngày hôm sau
vậy cũng có nói là cả hôm qua
thì tại sao mình gặp nói chuyện với
vì vậy cậu nhưng ở mình hai đứa bạn thân
ấy nhỉ Em thử kiểu hôm sau bạn ấy cậu
ngồi nghĩ kỹ lại và mình mới nhận ra cơ
Còn lúc lúc nói chuyện bình thường đấy
bạn đấy sẽ bị cuốn theo cái câu chuyện
đấy hiểu ông sẽ là người dẫn dắt để bạn
ơi cuốn heo thì tâm lý ông phải vững hơn
bạn ơi rất nhiều lúc tôi áp dụng được
mấy cái kiểu như thế này
anh em vừa rồi tao cũng là lời khuyên để
mày ông mà áp dụng không phải một thanh
cài ơi nhá rất nhiều trường hợp đâu có
thể làm thế được nhé
đi quay lại vẫn là việc thật nhạt kênh
trắng Dạy cách tán gái
lộ bản chất thì chứng tỏ là là ông đang
biến thành fanzone rồi
Ừ ông thật gà ông cách làm
em đánh nhanh thắng nhanh gì không gửi
vài ngày thôi
Có phải ngày ông phải rồi bài đi chơi
rồi thì tại con đang tò mò với ông trước
1 tuần họ nói chuyện với ông chán rồi
thì ông còn lâu mới dụ bạn đấy đi cà phê
nói chuyện được
Ok hôm nay tâm sự thì cũng hiểu rồi à
anh không một tiếng rồi Tôi không muốn
được hôm sau được nhiều không muốn xem
lại đâu Nói chung nhà
ở ngoài tạm kết thúc đẩy thế nhỉ
sao nhé
Chào mấy ông nhé